so you're still
she's still working on the technique but
i'm gonna make it a little more live
okay
so what's happening elbows in
push into my stomach
you see the post is making pot all i
gotta do is pull it
what are you supposed to do
lower the post once you truck the hit
lower it you too late you went from
straight arm to
hook
too far too far
this way
is
watch that 45
[Music]
the speed isn't gonna be it you're in
the same boat right
hey
if they after they can't get in a while
let them work on the form
work this problem smash the hands oh too
high
keep this down
smash the hands
there you go
you're gonna get elbo
okay
but when you are the live uke you're not
going to do a different art you're going
to keep doing the same yid young art
okay
so
uh when he bends his arms then i can
climb up do you see
if he has a good
i can't so i don't i don't try to do it
okay i only take the yins pigs that's
why you effortlessly lost your balance
got swept got stopped okay
so i'm not
trying to do
yong yang
clashes he goes
and i'm just looking for things you see
he brought his hand there but he's got a
good
post on my stomach i'm not going to do
anything with it so i don't try to do
anything
so this hand was a little low you see
and i got that knee in there
i'm just giving him things to work with
then i take my position
i'm not trying to beat him
i'm trading he's training in
this happened forms
go back i'll show you what's happening
if this knee can get in
this hand
is not
satisfying too close
yes you got to stop the shrimp
and now this knee you want to keep tight
there you go
oh watch how much you lean back bring
your hips forward there you go that's it
that's it
watch this
watch this again
[Music]
it's a little high right
you're doing the
taking the openings you want
you feel your muscle
it's not going to work is it so just let
it be
right
see this muscle
you want to push there
it's not going to work
so you've got that leverage
extend your arms more like i saw you
doing
amazing
maybe you're stronger here
you see but it gives a different opening
this one okay
so
this is a little worse for you isn't it
okay
try to see how relaxed like already
intense
not here
do you feel your balance
what do you think why are you posting
here
bend your elbow
lower yourself
okay now put your hips forward
that's it
good there you go
much better
let the guy get the guard
and then he lets you begin
elbows in
posture
relax
a lot of tension already
look at me
that's how you need to be okay
yeah
okay did you see it wasn't
shoving shoveling shovel
just feel feel feel
okay
don't
so as as i find the in space i make you
better as i get better okay
um
what do you think i'm ripped muscle yeah
right
get rid of that get rid of that somehow
look you're going to open yourself up
see
tap out earlier before you gag i should
never hear you get continue
it's really high
you see how high you will
get some weight on
see
it's really
hot set it up okay begin
watch this you just don't need
right you're so strong but go ahead
but my legs are gonna do this
so don't lean so far forward
don't worry about that just put this
down
knee slice
good and now your bottom leg will clear
the hook
right there
there you go just one again too high
pull down if you need to there you go
roll it up roll over and smash it
no
turn your body down and smash the arms
there you go now fix your legs
[Music]
even when you come up don't go
okay try to keep your posture keep your
posture
pulling your legs in for me
and you go like this pull it
posture look up
don't worry about that leg
just here knee slice is plenty now drop
your weight
on the guy you see right this way then
your hips come through
you see and they cleared the bottom left
but
i'm heavy on
you're going to push me let's say
you see
only if i resist
go back
you push i'm gonna turn
nice
start
feeling the in space
yes
feeling in space do something with your
hands so i don't punch you
so
you feel the way
just play with your balance
and i play with your balance
oh
try for the knee slice
lower yourself you're really high
you feel your balance it's gonna get
taken isn't it
i
feel it
you see it's right there
feel that man like you're surfing okay
try it again
here you balance
but you stood for me
all you need is your knee to get in
there
bottom knee
lay down
hip more hip hips there you go
and then lay down immediately
better get this get this post
forget this arm don't worry go around
the energy
push that out shoulder into me there you
go look
what happens as you learn the form is
you you don't realize it but
you become attached to
the structures of the form
so
even if you're trying to operate at an
energetic level yin and yang
it is important but yin and yang is
relative
to a context
and you do not need to become attached
to the context so
she's gonna go
[Music]
what ends up keep going i'm gonna talk
to some other if you know what i'm
saying okay
uh right keep going
i can move out of
a side controllable position
[Music]
of defending side control okay
and then
you can start to make her better because
her mind has to become
less attached
hi so one way that you can let go of
defending side keep going i can talk
of defending side control
is
you're looking to
more of attacking with side control
you have to quit
get some balance man go
start thinking outside the blocks of
side control
you can't be too upset enough to drool
again you're so stuck go
get some balance
so keep going okay i can't move
but your body mind stuck
thanks go
thanks you have to stay here but
nothing's stopping you
and part of her technique is to stop me
part of your training is to get unstuck
i like the expression
i i got no business being here defending
against her
try to try to go like no i don't think
so what is over there
okay
feel
when they get stuck
because they think you're stuck
and then unstick yourself and you will
be much more able to
reconcile greater yin yang